this is not a French this is not a front
a Koval hot sauce all the city's bad for
you like I [ __ ] with it the most so this
wasn't even uh
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings it's a
special day I'm joined in the studio by
yg the album still breezy you can get it
now you plug inline 400 online yg
welcome to the show
who's pop it's a hotsauce show I hear
that you're a hot sauce guy
how you feeling going into this one I'm
ready I'm going oh you okay that's good
to know that's good to know and it's
worth acknowledging we had a little bit
of a wing mishap so Nuggets from
chick-fil-a because we had to scramble
real quick for yg it's gonna be an
interesting episode because we're gonna
just have to take out these Nuggets
ready to do this thing I'm ready
so the first one is sriracha sriracha
that's no big deal right you eat with me
or huh
when you're on GGN snoop spoke about how
to knit and boot it while it might have
been a Billboard chart 50s or 60s it was
the number one song in the streets so
much so in fact that 50 and Snoop jumped
on the remix and what didn't even charge
you
snowball ways know about me because the
kids on his football team was always my
rabbit my music like the photo a moon
even popped off so he always knew my
juanzi he was having on me because of
that like he like I'm [ __ ] mawashi he
didn't act youngling up from the city he
official Pam and in 50-day just hop
darling he dropped it like on the side
of something like he's dropped his
version and then how'd you meet 50 I
heard you like
yes scrambled up to him and usually you
don't run up to people right no he was
uh he was leaving Interscope I was
leaving Def Jam you know I was pulling
out and my boy be more like that's fifty
in a song and just came like he'll just
put the song up there more I poured upon
a how about the core
I walked up today [ __ ] like what's
happening hey know who I was though
great which can get a little hairy
sometimes and you so was boy bust up the
quorum like his lodgings like like oh
[ __ ] what's up yeah oh my - oldest a
knife and he came out to the show at the
Key Club he is how happened you know
real [ __ ] [ __ ] can you talk about your
relationship with Russell Westbrook
because I followed both of you guys and
he seems to support your music and
likewise you seem to support his
basketball career would you say that you
guys are friends mhm
it's just like all a [ __ ] I sang with
James Horton all him I'm a Thunder fan
so they start coming to the crib
you feel me early on all of them duel
James Horton
Westbrook and Durant
come up I seen them come up we are from
that way everybody support each other so
like when the Thunder were playing
against the Clippers are playing against
the Lakers
I'm warmth with thunder Westbrook and
Zhang's Horton Zhang's horn from Bombay
was both like you feel maybe young
[ __ ] up next I'm [ __ ] with them
period you're a bit of a fast food
connoisseur I know that you liked
Tam's in LA and five guys but if I'm not
mistaken pizza your favorite maybe yeah
I want to show you four of the most
iconic big pizza chains and I want you
to rank them from best to worst the ones
that you like the ones that you don't
like I just want to get your thoughts on
pizza you're ready let's do it
all right Papa John's what do you think
of Papa John's Papa's gonna solve it
Domino's but when you can't you know
know Papa John's Domino's the next Pizza
Hut piece of this first Pizza Hut number
one yeah my first not a crust you can't
make out the best crust to me piece off
I told Little Caesars do you ever go
with the $5 hot and ready what do you
think a little Caesar that's when you
wanna run real fast like you want a
little some you got a gang of homes we
should just what our gang of
[ __ ] a little sweet and sour
boxes but I I love a breadstick stuff
that's breadsticks Little Caesars they
got the best breadsticks so can we rank
them number one
Pizza Hut right these move more people
we're dropping John's number two Little
Caesar Domino's number three
Little Caesars a war but the breadsticks
you unfuck with a bowl you
I'm like this me well you could take out
Caribbean habanero that's your favorite
so far
what is so looser everywhere man you can
get that anywhere you want mm-hmm I know
that your daughter recently had our
first birthday
and I think on first birthdays you can
go one of two ways either you do it
really big because it's the first
birthday or you go you know what it's a
one-year-old
you know maybe we just get some cupcakes
she's not gonna sweat the details and
we'll save the big birthday for later on
how did you approach it big blowout or
sort of a low-key thing it was low-key
we gonna go big we should get a little
older and she knows like it's big you
found me I spent like 15 bands on my
face your toes that's a big that's
bigger than my first birthday I'm gonna
call my dad when this shoots over the
spa I forgot the name always called
giggles and wolves I just feel like all
the rich people will take the kids to
play [ __ ] y'all better be hot you don't
have to automatically give our hot sauce
a good review like if you think it sucks
let me know it sucks you know what I'm
saying
we'll do it so it's kind of sweet
you're the stagers blend but it lights
up your mouth a little bit but it's not
hot by the book yg what do you think
you're not you're shaking your head at
me this license [ __ ] sweet solstice
on everybody it's hot a little bit I
know you want it hotter
beautiful good thing we got a little bit
later on in the show it gets a little
weird up in here so for my next question
what I want to do is sometimes what we
like to do is go through somebody's
Instagram and pick out the pictures that
kind of pop to us that are interesting
that we need to know more about you can
just tell me what's going on what you
remember about that day what that moment
means to you sound good
Oh y'all so having a suit you got a cool
view oh [ __ ] Ewan is this Bieber's Lambo
he doesn't be reliable and just said
y'all son celebrate what's going on here
see we want away to beaver house you
can't just leave me there I need to know
more like we would drive muffled by baby
Aaron we like Ozzy for what it
it's a logical wonder of this
[ __ ] you know what I kind of
like Bob Bieber is he seems real like
liberal with his keys like everyone's
always driving Bieber's cars around it
just seems like if you're cool with
Bieber and you're in that circle
oh just oz was driving but it was real
like it was like this this one you ha ha
ha front row at the Gulf Lane show and
this is interesting
Tom's and the bulletproof vest I need to
know more about this picture see what
more do you need to know why Tom a
bulletproof vest I [ __ ] with Tom I know
you love I just thought [ __ ] with him
if I [ __ ] with him heavy no different
that's my swagger go see that I said
look sue it nice and this is quite the
front row you got easy there you got DJ
mustard there you familiar had a student
like bhai Kanye Kanye got beer like no
put them in a front [ __ ] the one really
real [ __ ] so this is Dean this is a
funny one to me I will [ __ ] up clearly
people always post party pics all the
time but nobody ever posts the hungover
pic and nobody ever posts like the one I
going this way the other one going this
way you did can you talk about that
decision to post that cuz I think more
people should do stuff like that no why
do you don't give a flying foot how's it
feeling little sweet oh yeah hot dog
when you learned that the Secret Service
was interested in investigating or
censoring the music and [ __ ] Donald
Trump's how do you find out do they
write you an email or do they just start
banging on your door the Secret Service
told Deb geumja sent all the lyrics or
the whole army if somebody wanted to
take all lyrics a table and then did
they just send back certain things that
were marked out and then you static
those things out the heat it was like
Chinese I don't like I'm not changing
[ __ ] right
just blank it out from study shoot I got
far as I understand why it was on a
sensitive record but they when they was
pointing off alone I'm like oh you see
if you do well you probably get smoked I
was like damn here we did it okay I get
it
you let me ask you this you know when
you're playing [ __ ] Donald Trump at
Coachella you have the whole place going
nuts but I wonder blue state - red state
does the environment for that song chain
yes for sure so what happens to the
crowd when you're like [ __ ] I have fun
we'll [ __ ] off a half of stand there
and look like they mad as a [ __ ]
you feel me
I'll be like this [ __ ] playing
whoa how I'm trying to blow this [ __ ] up
so this one is pain 100%
to me it's the worst tasting hot sauce
when people talk about your politically
charged songs they always talk about
[ __ ] Donald Trump but there's one song
that in my opinion should probably get a
little bit more attention a little bit
more credit I'm talking about blacks and
browns because it really looks at
something that the mainstream never
talks about and that's how
african-american and Hispanic
communities coexist can you talk a
little bit about how that song came
about and why you pegged sad boy for the
song the bass heart like how we deep we
don't get a home be sure they like in LA
because there's gang infested so you do
got right I'm blacklisted be for
Hispanics but you got a lot black people
love expanding suspending a little black
we grew up with each other we we share a
lot of the same stuff we [ __ ] with a
sisters they [ __ ] with our sisters like
we take food they eat our food like you
fill me sauce like a love-hate
relationship due to the gang [ __ ] but i
nobody would like brought that to the
light and like let more focus no like
nah we following each other like rocky
and [ __ ] I use allowed us all the time
Oh how's the hot sauce doing for you I
think I'm probably catching it worse
than you are right now you're always
saying nothing wrong
I'm the album if you listen to the sad
boy verse there's a line where it's
static out somebody ring
[Music]
Jasper disrespected was that censorship
as it relates to Donald Trump or
whatever really what does he say you say
you ain't trying to make America great
[ __ ] you guys say please somebody bring
them to birthdays have them meet Mike
wet day just for disrespect you from you
so he's saying bring them bring them to
the 13th that's like you filming that
little gang [ __ ] and have a meet Mike
wet day that's a good just for
disrespect so they like nah can't say
that baby we like what like next one is
de bomb beyond insanity hot sauce how's
your mouth feeling nauseous is a little
bit what is life that's a part of
Eatonville exactly do you kind of enjoy
that feeling as regu that's it that's
some [ __ ] talking about yg the LA
cookout is something that's celebrated a
lot both in music videos and in movies
and even a lot of your music videos have
sort of a block party type of atmosphere
so I want to construct the perfect
fourth of July cookout but with your
help ok so I need some help
first up what is the best side dish is
it mac and cheese is a potato salad is
it corn on the cob or is it something
else I don't eat cheese in lactose so uh
if you ask somebody else that they're
gonna say man 1g I'll [ __ ] with the
Ponca that's the cookout anthem is it
summertime in LBC by the dub shack you
know that one you know that there's
plenty of them you guys are [ __ ] I get
around you got two gin and juice you got
the Kelly's active she if you were to
look back at your catalogue what would
you say is your best to cookout song
there's a block party is there something
else damn you got like to UM record you
got to I'm a third [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
you broke the left right how do you get
people out of your house when you want
them to leave that's a big cookout issue
that people have a man like that was
issue me
I sit at my house I used to always at my
house
[ __ ] ain't leaving most folks is
spinning at night they don't want to
leave much while my see why she was a
bot sit with papi you got to be like all
right I'm about to leave everybody gotta
go I'm about to go got something to do
then you go around the corner come back
here there's the old fake oldest trick
in the book
[Music]
alright so this next one is mad dog 357
yg with the Nugget full Mad Dog 357 if
you can get through this this is gonna
be
I've never seen anything like it all my
life Todd laughs we've got hot after him
what about this one it's hot blue you
can deal yeah y'all gonna put enough hot
sauce only thank [ __ ] yeah oh you're the
first guest to walk in here and be like
next time up the ante is not this is not
a front alcohol hot sauce all this it's
bad for you that I got [ __ ] with the
most so this wasn't right now what are
you going through nothing really wash it
like it's hot but it ain't like I can
take it hot it's like all right you just
silly [ __ ] oh yeah we didn't grow that's
how to take the hospital away right are
you trying to take my show cuz I think
you could no problem I want you show you
do this make it one ticket and get a
percentage can you talk a little bit
about the decision to get the Virgin
Mary tattooed on your head was that's
something that you've thought about for
a long time or was a kind of an impulse
decision not always son I was thinking
about for a minute she's getting it
finishing my like my hair cuz I decide
in the back and all that [ __ ] was
already done centenary mm ah I just got
popped falls on my little who shot me
[ __ ] y'all I'm unstoppable [ __ ] and you
know I had to get I had to get Jesus
moms cuz I got him on sorry right here I
thought I got Jesus face and I say
I say gas so I just want to feel I want
to finish the whole [ __ ] I got across in
the back with the cross saying [ __ ] I
forgot what the Cross say because I
can't never see
this last wing is Blair's loss that's
what we're gonna do if you're game for
it which I have a feeling you're going
to be so this is Blair's Megadeth sauce
with liquid rage it is our hottest hot
sauce and yg this is no exaggeration the
single most impressive performance we've
ever had on hot ones you've been
cleaning these nuggets
I'll tell you from firsthand experience
the Nuggets are just as hot as the wings
they're the same hot sauce they're all
on these Nuggets it's absolutely amazing
what you've done a little bit of fiji
water but that's no big deal look at the
dent in that bottle that's nothing
so what we do with the last one which we
dabbed the last wing this is again
Blair's Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
a little drop on there
be careful Ayaka pour it on those
fissures and dip it yeah whatever move
you want to go with cuz that is generous
a lot of guys get cocky on the last wing
got that's a Glock that's a glob this is
outrageous
once you got broke do you think you
tomorrow do you think I need to do more
you dip your [ __ ] Amash it though all
right is that it oh let me see you shake
it oh let me see yours oh I wanna take
your show over you ready
is this good yeah you saw them all right
so I want to ask you the question first
because I want you to just think about
it while the hot sauce is hitting you
okay I know you loved that Allred
Maybach right and a lot of people think
that that's basically a perfect car but
it can't be perfect maybe the cup holder
is too small maybe it slides a little in
wintry conditions I want you to give me
one complaint to complaints whatever you
have about the Maybach all right ready
cheers Maji
I bro
[Music]
nothing but I said that is not hot like
him
this one was hotter no no but that one
hit your husband was hotter than this
one and this one and I think this one
the hottest oh you katako caribbean
habanero near bro well I don't know
what's going on with you know these two
the hottest yg you flip the game atomic
hot sauce from wing style is hotter than
always shoot it is not but whatever
crazy actually hotter than a
[ __ ] complaints about the mail
I'm feeling like some [ __ ] my throat oh
I'm full of [ __ ] I'm feeling some [ __ ]
yeah yeah
I'll fill in some suit you
you may buy complaints lay back hang on
over playable it's gotta be something it
can't be the perfect hot now yep how you
brought us a light life creeping up on
your heel yeah [ __ ] how does it bother
you gotta give me a me back complaint
I'll be riding around with the homies a
lifetime home he's gonna smoke weed
ashes all in my [ __ ] [ __ ] blah traps
everywhere and [ __ ] they give him that
car they get in the Maybach and do it
like that like if I kiss a beaut I treat
like a security [ __ ] and tell them all
the time bro like don't make a mess of
my shape no how much is parked on thing
without the white Steve that's the only
thing God Chang's black and to you you
get a darker interior to hide the blunt
stains
fair enough for me yg you made it
through cleared the board yeah it's very
hot but all of these are hot and the way
that you just kind of cruise through the
challenge so easy you're the new hot
ones King as far as I'm concerned the
Hat might as well be a crown the floor
is yours let the people know what you
have going on in your life you got a
cell table now I was great do you know
we got a doodle we gotta get the Grammy
community to game on nominations let me
ask you this you remember how you said I
do remember how you said with the last
album that it was a slap in the face
that you didn't get a nomination yeah
what about this time around if they if
they skip you again what would that be
some race you shoot some races [ __ ] so
that's what you got to take with your
plug hey voting committee people if you
happen to be watching hot ones which I'm
sure they all do why don't you check
YG's box out there huh
my [ __ ] is high
[Music]